[Music]  the Parliament is organizing a week of  events for the 70th anniversary of the  Universal Declaration of Human Rights a  high-level conference will focus on how  to integrate Human Rights in business  sustainable development and external  action better Social Security for  cross-border workers is on the table the  aim is to allow them to receive  unemployment benefits and health  services even when they've changed  country members vote to better protect  whistleblowers acting in the public  interest they would have legal and  financial aid and help protecting their  identity members vote on rules to limit  workers exposure to new cancer-causing  chemicals particularly in laboratories  construction work and the textile  industry Parliament debates clear  regulations on autonomous vehicles like  self-driving cars and automated aircraft  it wants to promote real-life testing  and new research while ensuring data  protection and consumer safety  [Music]